please join me in extending an to
sziasztok round of applause for the
class of 2019 student speaker
Hamza Qureshi Thank You president Jehan
e'en for the introduction first off
thank you and congratulations to my
fellow graduates
I'd also yeah I'd also like to thank
everyone who's helped me get here my
family friends professors mentors I
dedicate this to you my journey to
Carnegie Mellon started roughly nine
years ago believe it or not from an
episode of 90210 where one of the main
characters name dropped us now I doubt
that at the time the writers anticipated
that mentioning CMU on their show would
inspire a random thirteen-year-old from
New Jersey to start planning for the
next decade of his life but Here I am I
visited campus for the first time in
2013 and came again in 2014 for
pre-college before coming here full-time
in 2015 I spent my summer exhausting my
resources reading anything that I could
find online about what it's like to
actually go to Carnegie Mellon at one
point I came across a post on a forum
somewhere where the author described
Carnegie Mellon as this grim and harsh
environment where people drop like flies
they wrote that when you come to CMU you
come simply to study and to learn and
that if that doesn't work for you you
won't make it out they wrote that
Carnegie Mellon is Pittsburgh's last
remaining steel factory churning out
turning out supremely educated yet
soulless students one by one
now the reason that I think about that
post after all these years is because
time and time again Carnegie Mellon and
its people have shown me that it
couldn't be more wrong my time here has
taught me so many things first that
drive is the greatest Incubus of change
that drive and passion aren't just a
part of success they're a part of what
makes us happy that when our hearts are
really truly in the work that we're
doing we can create incredible things
from extravagant sets for the big senior
show to social media startups to
elaborate booths built and torn down in
just a week to robots that assemble
grilled cheese sandwiches for you see
the mark of a Carnegie Mellon student is
this incessant need to create we work
tirelessly to make things better for
those around us and as we journey on to
the next phase of our lives let us not
forget the impact that our world that
our work can have on the world as
Carnegie Mellon graduates we have the
power to develop the technology that'll
lead us to the future the power to
resolve conflicts amongst our teams our
companies and maybe even our nation's
the power to move people with our art
and as the world around us continues to
change we must use what we've learned
during our time here to keep creating
keep changing keep doing because
creativity stops when we do over my time
at Carnegie Mellon I've also seen what
it really means to change change is not
something I'm averse to I was born in
Pakistan and I moved to the United
States with my family in 1998 I went on
to experience these elements have
changed throughout my life while at the
same time watching the world change
around me and on the surface I've seen
Carnegie Mellon changed so much over the
past four plus years we've gotten a new
university president
two new gyms we even got a new business
school with the lobby bigger than the
Pittsburgh airports while looking inward
I've seen the community change too i've
seen us become more and more resilient
by joining together in the face of deep
turmoil and tragedy we've become more
open about the problems that we're
facing and we've started working
together to find ways to work past them
we've also become more proactive in
driving the change we want to see for
ourselves and our people around us as we
move forward keep in mind that it isn't
always about changing our communities
changing our environments or even
changing the world
sometimes it's about finding those
opportunities for change within yourself
and so class of 2019 my charge to you is
this as we continue to watch ourselves
change throughout the course of our
lives remember the times when even just
for a moment things felt familiar
remember the moments when you succeeded
at things you didn't think you could and
when remember the moments you failed
when you didn't expect to remember the
morning spent in lecture were the only
thing you knew was that you had no idea
what was going on
remember the afternoons and the evenings
spent with your student orgs laughing
and smiling and arguing each other's
company and remember the nights that you
might not remember all too well
see change is inevitable but the way
that you remember the memories that led
you there is entirely up to you and my
hope is that the overzealous sixteen
year olds sitting at the computer
researching what life is like as a CMU
student are able to see it the same way
I did during my time here that they can
see the same opportunities for passion
for growth and for change if Carnegie
Mellon really is Pittsburgh's last
remaining steel factory then it's clear
that we are not spending our time on the
assembly lines we're writing complex
algorithms for autonomy building and
testing the machinery meticulously
designing and planning the interior
spaces figuring out how to manage all of
the teams and of course grabbing a
sandwich at the exchange as often as we
can our days at Carnegie Mellon may have
been tough but with the memories that
we've all made here those days have also
been some of our best thank you so much
once again for the opportunity to speak
to you all today as we move forward let
us not forget that no matter how
separated by distance we may find
ourselves we can always find ways to
move forward together thank you
thank you